[Music]
where's the wall debris these two
minutes of credits continue to be
unrealistic and a waste of hard precious
time which honestly makes them fit in
with the rest of season 8 pretty well
i'm so tired of the body objectification
of a camera scanning from toe to head of
a character he's a corpse for pete's
dragon's sake i don't care how dead sexy
you find jorah enough of this pale gaze
once again i'm bemused by the lighting
choices this show makes since it's
resulted in theon looking a thousand
percent more ginger than he actually is
and even more bafflingly makes sansa
look like she gives a [ __ ] that he's
dead we're here to say goodbye to our
brothers and sisters only two of them
were really all that important and
honestly even they were fairly
dispensable but hey there's probably at
least three seasons of the show left so
no rush in doing anything too dramatic
everyone in this world
owes them a debt that can never be
repaid but the reward for those who
fought and survived is to march through
the snow for two weeks to fight another
war that also ends up being decided by a
dragon anyway honestly i think cremation
may actually be preferable it is our
duty and our honor to skip for as long
as men's your breath you know i should
draw breath the cg artist how am i
supposed to believe it's cold out here
when i can't even see anyone doing any
atmospheric vaping
pyro romania i was kind of hoping to see
the on expanse of this funeral but they
died as they lived shrouded in
frustrating darkness also show spends a
full 5 minutes and 47 seconds displaying
mourning and burning the dead this
episode did not need to be an hour and
17 minutes long and i swear it's mocking
me into noting every occasion of
self-indulgence until we identify what
the true run time should have been lucy
and i are you can still smell the
burning bodies and that's where your
head is at clegane is addicted gendry's
head
wait
you are aware he took my family's throne
and tried to have me murdered taner
spends about three minutes trolling
gendry before awarding him a lordship
instead of just getting to the good part
i swear the writers made every part of
this season into a metaphor for the
season itself
last time i saw her
i told her i'd kill her if i ever saw
her again this entire scene is sir davos
telling tyrion something we already know
and he doesn't care about and tyrion
replying with something we also already
know and sir davos doesn't particularly
care about i guess because hey isn't it
cool that these two people are talking
and for some reason we had to make every
episode a feature-length movie we play
his game from we fight as war and win
and then
he [ __ ] off
no signs no blessings who knows what he
wants benny often twice his unfiltered
thoughts on george rr martin somehow
make their way into the script your turn
you
are an only child
i told you i was sho has time for this
actually i think that's the official
tagline on the season a poster what kind
of person climbs on a [ __ ] dragon a
madman or a king we will now linger on
daenerys processing this profound
statement with brooding and ominous
music behind her as if this is the first
time she's ever had to deal with how
sexism might impact her rule she's been
a badass giving zero [ __ ] up until now
but the show wants to plant some seeds
so that it'll make sense as her
character makes a story shift through
seasons 9 and 10. you're a virgin sweet
i was hoping one of the plot lines
during the overstuffed season a would be
a quest for brienne to lose her
virginity like some sort of 80 sex
comedy game of thrones losing it let's
go we did it
we faced those icy f
my celebratory outburst after completing
my frosty the snowman inspired sex tape
somehow makes its way into the episode
tormund stares at brienne jamie stares
at tormund tormund stares at jaime
tormund stares at tyrion tyrion stares
at tormund podrick stares at tormund
tormund stares at podrick is this season
sponsored by stairmaster this [ __ ]
comes north and takes her from me one
positive i'll give season eight is that
it really did try to tie up every single
loose end even the ones we don't give a
[ __ ] about like tormund pursuing brienne
i'm sure everyone was dying to know
where that was leading and equally
relieved when the answer was nowhere
seem much worse than you since then
being called the nicest kid at
bullycamp practicing your archery around
hundreds of drunk people be my wife
be the lady of storm's end
turning down a proposal with an intimate
kiss
kiss him fine but at least they know
first it's bloody hot in here using
british nelly as your seduction
technique he loved me
and i couldn't love him back i mean
mostly it's that we weren't even related
in any way so really what's the point
now that we're done talking about the
dead guy i'd like to snog my nephew by
the fire for a bit okay
what happens when they demand you press
your claim and take what is mine
i'll refuse what is john thinking i get
that he's in love but does he really not
see how that idea is pointless i'm not
upset that johnny snows is submissive
i'm upset that he's suddenly dumb
i have to tell sansa and i
sansa
will want to see me gone and you on the
iron throne problem with this argument
is that we know john has no intention of
not telling arya and sansa and dany has
no intention of backing down and risking
her claim to the throne this episode is
filled with arguments that we have no
chance of being invested in because
eight years of fantastic character
development has already told us the
outcome this postcoital shot of jaime
and brienne is just here as a reminder
that these two played sword and sheath
together no dialogue just a few seconds
of refresher since you've probably
forgotten it happened among the other 25
minutes of absolutely nothing that's
gone on in the episode so far and now
more of your favorite part of game of
thrones strategizing over maps why get
to the actual battle when you could have
people just stand around talking about
it instead we need a word of course you
do all anybody does in this episode is
say words this episode is so full of
people standing around saying things
that imdb actually classifies this
episode's genre as talk show oh yeah
we're family arya toretto here is
suggesting what that the four of them
can take on the entire world lead the
seven kingdoms from winterfell why does
she even care isn't she just trying to
chase down all the people on her list
the last of the starks we're all
commercials
if only i need to tell you something
but you have to swear
you'll never tell another soul john of
course spills the incestuous beans to
arya and sansa but he can't truly
believe they're going to keep this to
themselves can he john isn't stupid and
he is a great tactician so what's the
advantage to telling them at all if the
goal is to make sure they follow danny
this final season is like trying to
solve a rubik's cube by peeling off the
stickers and putting them in the right
place yeah you'll get it in the end but
it's pretty time consuming and not at
all satisfying but also finally some
talking that might be interesting seeing
the star kids react to this news is
going to be fascinating will they
immediately push back on their vow to
keep it secret will they congratulate
him on being unbastardized will their
faces be tinged with joy fear anger if
there's one scene that's going to be
worth all this incessant talking it's
going to be and we're already cutting
away aren't we also also before deciding
that the most important conversational
bomb drop would happen off screen john
told bran to tell them this is not the
kind of information you tell second hand
especially through bran you would make
winning the lottery sound depressing you
boys are a part of gold-plated putting
molten gold anywhere near your genitals
he's not going to kill us he wouldn't be
tortured
but this only proves that braun's
willing to kill a chair with the
crossbow not either of them kill a few
hundred people that make you a lord kill
a few thousand then make you king kill
the last season of an entire fantasy
novel series they make you a star wars
director
my fighting days are done because of
course no one wants to see braun or
tormund kicking ass in the finale so
let's just sideline them entirely we
wouldn't want to risk having fun now
would we
some unfinished business
me too what's the name of the version of
the pronoun game where characters just
talk in generalities about their plans
instead of just saying the thing that
they mean bland plan gaming detail
failed gaming can this show just quit
talking about stuff and actually do it
uh
gaming take these broken wings and learn
to fly again
so convenient and easy
why huh sansa says this while literally
looking at the most convincing
two-winged fire-breathing reasons
circling her the men in my family don't
do well in the capital ha-ha get it
because my dad got his head chopped off
there i'm funny what if there's someone
else
someone better
why are all the interesting
conversations happening off-screen yeah
you're not gonna ride the dragon south
regal needs to heal he doesn't need me
wearing him down oh for [ __ ] sake
they're going to kill rhaegal aren't
they this is fair well then and now a
full 3 minutes and 18 seconds of john
saying goodbye to three people and a dog
this waste of time makes me particularly
mad because this could have been
convincingly done in under a minute and
90 percent of that minute should have
been telling ghost that he's the goodest
boy ever also this lineup of important
goodbyes processional couldn't have been
more conveniently arranged and timed if
they were stationed and released by a
wedding planner
oh for double [ __ ] sake they're gonna
kill missandei too aren't they how many
others know including us
eight
no
not including you he literally asked how
many others no tyrion words mean
something damn it also pretending like
sam hasn't already spilled the news to
gilly
[Music]
somehow from above they fail to notice a
weapon that has to have line of sight to
even work the show wants us to believe
this was a surprise hit but there is no
possible universe where these boats are
a surprise to these dragons or daenerys
also why are they even flying so low i
think they'd be smart enough to run some
high elevation reconnaissance before
just dragon bombing into the bay all
willy-nilly also also they hit heart
wing and throat kill shot on their first
three shots rhaego is clearly not a luck
dragon diving head first towards the
killer crossbows instead of coming
around and toasting their ass from
behind despite hitting three perfect
shots euron and his fleet will now miss
every following shot because somehow
they know there's no way dany's story
was ever going to end here it took 54
minutes of pointless conversation to get
here but we have made it to some action
i'd like to take a sin off but my limit
on pointless conversation to start a
television show is 50 minutes so close
then also the action lasts less than a
minute and if there's one thing i know
for sure it's that you never get credit
if you last under a minute
this is without a single shadow of a
doubt the most pointless did the falling
thing kill a character oh we don't know
because it faded to black fake out
cliche ever there's no [ __ ] way that
this is how tyrion goes out and even if
the show thinks that we were gullible
enough to believe it was we're given
less than 15 seconds to sit with that
shock before it's immediately revealed
he's safely on shore what is the [ __ ]
point of this episode
this is a mistake handling daenerys
transformation into the mad queen in the
final two episodes so it feels like a
crazy woman trope instead of an earned
character descent yeah hard agree he
doesn't want the throne
that's why he bent the knee didn't these
two just have this conversation on the
boat like 10 minutes ago does he not
remember how hard did tyrion's head get
hit by that mast i don't think it is a
true qualification as i'm sure you'd
agree hey don't make fun of him for not
having a penis there's an actual phrase
for the kind of person that would do
that you taunt i believe in our queen
she'll make the right choice first you
believed in cersei and now you believe
in daenerys when did tyrion turn into a
hopeful optimist and more importantly
when did he lose his cynical wisdom and
guile the show seems to want me to start
feeling things for this incestuous lech
who attempted casual child murder and
still hasn't really done anything that
wasn't self-serving there is no moral
tension here jaime even makes this point
here in about 60 seconds so what i still
don't understand is this if i know this
and you know this and even jamie knows
this how does the show not know this i
pushed a boy at a tower window crippled
him for life you know what i think i've
got it do you remember when sitcoms
would run out of money or ideas so they
put together a clip show where the main
characters would reminisce about all the
[ __ ] they've been through yeah 50 of
this episode is that but without the
clips and somehow even more boring this
dragon is grounded in in range how is
cersei not taking shots at it why is she
not just obliterating all of them right
now this is cersei we're talking about
right there's this neat trick i've seen
other shows do i think it's called
editing or something basically it saves
you from having to film every single
footstep across every single second that
passes so that your show can be a less
than an hour long and b entertaining my
lord i'm only a mouthpiece for our queen
and puppets cersei is queen of the seven
kingdoms you are her subject the rain is
over great another immovable
uninteresting object arguing with
another unstoppably boring force
you've always loved your children i just
watched a dragonfly take a nosedive into
my coffee and choose the sweet release
of death by caramel latte rather than
continue to watch its ancestors being
disgraced by this drivel that is where
dragonflies come from right the rain is
over doesn't mean your baby has to die
i've always found threatening a mother's
child to be a really effective way of
preventing combat this character
actually used to be smart right i'm not
just imagining that
we've been trying to contact you
regarding your car's extended warranty
harold crick was a man of infinite
numbers endless calculations and
remarkably few words so whose lord of
storm's end now
i don't know your grace does anyone
anyone
anyone
it's okay
his uh his mother just died i've never
slept with a night before
take me the pleasure down
i've never begged for anything
but i'm begging you
don't do this
please
whatever i do what i want
your sister offered me river rod she's
beautiful she's rich she's got huge
tracks of land yes well liam
the nights have been getting longer i
need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately when you tell him that the
moon is out of orbit i'm sure he knows
how it happens sam
come on